viele fragen sich wahrscheinlich auch
luca die wie die liste zeigt folglich
fällt aber mein name ist herzlich
willkommen hier zu einem neuen video am
dienstag die dienstag
ich habe schon mal gefragt ob ihr alle
schuhe sehen wollt die ich so besitze
weil das echte menge ist ich habe ihr
geraten einen kompletten corp neben mir
liegen und viele haben sich wirklich
dafür interessiert deswegen werde ich
jetzt erstmal ein paar schuhe zeigen die
eigentlich keinen großen hintergrund
hamm und ein paar andere schuhe wozu ich
euch auf jeweils meine story erzählen
könnte also ja ich zeige euch mal die
ersten die ersten schuhe sind nike free
666 punkten fünf neue free 4.0 die hier
die sind ein bisschen dreckig ja nur zum
joggen oder manchmal zum joggen und sind
sauer bequem ja dann auch nike sind
irgendwelche hau mich tot irgendwelchem
weißen teil habe ich von nike mal zu
gesicht bekommen von einem jahr hatte
ich tatsächlich noch nie an
deswegen sind die auch eher
uninteressant glaube ich dann kommen wir
zum einen hallenfußball schulen
beziehungsweise auf kunstrasen da unten
drunter sind auch noch ein paar kurven
körner schwarze nike heißen die glaube
ich die war sehr geil weil die halt so
eine riesige summe von hat womit man ihm
schießen konnte die sache einmal die
komplette
ach das haben wir gekriegt wieder ich
habe einen freistoß mal übel zu den
boden getreten und mich zum affen
gemacht und dabei ist die sole einfach
so abgebrochen
ja ich bekomme nun zu zwei paar fans die
ich auch schon sehr lange haare und zwar
einmal diese ganz normalen weißen welt
hier die sind von unten nicht mehr so
weiß tatsächlich und so dunkelblaue fast
schon wieder ne wenn die sache mit denen
es geht schon von innen sind diese ein
bisschen er zerstört das sieht daher
daran weil ich mal einlagen tragen
musste und dann haben wir da die sohle
raus gemacht und haben dann da die
einlage eingelegt habe ich nur noch
tragen konnte die sache ist das hat die
schuhe komplett mitgenommen und jetzt
sind die halt beide vollkommen am arsch
und ich kann dir eigentlich beide nicht
mehr anziehen
irgendwie sehr traurig die nächsten
schule sind komplett durch gefeiert
chucks in schwarze weht schon die sind
komplett dreckig vorne und an allen
ich einen anderen seiten weil ich sie
einfach immer zum feiern an ziehe das
ist einfach man kann die hose
hochkrempeln und die schuhe nimmt es
dann zwar irgendwie kompletten mit aber
irgendwie ich mich marktcheck sie sind
komplett bequem das ist auch schon das
zweite modell das ich von denen habe ich
hatte früher schon mal schwarze und das
sind jetzt irgendwie neue die sind aber
trotzdem total dreckig aus die nächsten
zwei jahre schule sind ebenfalls und
zwar einmal diese geilen weißen chucks
die also wenig leute zum lügner haben
ich glaube jeder zweite hat die
irgendwie zu hause ab und dann noch die
gleichen jobs in blau weil ich trage sie
auf blau und blog ihr seht schon dass
ich gerade eine habe ich hab grad schon
wieder ein blaues t shirt an deswegen
die sich eigentlich relativ häufig an
die weder die sind gar nicht mal so
dreckig also die haben sich halt einmal
draußen er die taxi weiter steht nahezu
gar nicht an weil ich habe tatsächlich
keine ahnung wie sollte nicht mehr
anziehen irgendwie standen die ich habe
halt unten sondern ablage für schuhe und
da drüber oder drüber stehen immer die
die ich nie anziehung darunter einmal
nur die die ich immer anziehe und die
standard gegenüber oben deswegen habe
ich ihn die an aber ich weiß nicht warum
das hier sind flip flops habe ich mir in
new york in einem outlet von ralph
lauren gekauft diese ultra bequem hatte
ich tatsächlich bis ihr es einmal anders
die sind auch richtig schmutzig von
unten alter eher flip flops sind keine
interessanten schuhe also die habe ich
mir auf jeden fall
eine maut gekauft diese hier das sind
ziemlich schenkt mir aufmerksamkeit
das sind die free 3.0 die sind ultra
bequem
übrigens ist es gar kein placement für
ihnen eine marke kauft euch die schule
die ihr feiert macht was ihr wollt ihr
mit eurem leben aber das hier ist kein
placement oder enkeln werbeschild für
irgend ein paar fällig der leiste ich
immer zum joggen dann hatte ich auch bei
der völker bei meisterschaft auf
prosieben an nur das sind halt schuhe
mit denen man auffällt also guckt euch
das an allein die sohle ist irgendwie
neongelb von außen sind die orange finde
ich pass sehr cool sehen weiß ausfindig
aber ist natürlich nicht jedermanns
sache kommen wir jetzt zwei paar schuhen
die ein bisschen schicker sind und zwar
sind das hier meine winterschuhe so ein
bisschen die sache ist nur die hatte ich
die gemüter gar nicht an glaube ich weil
die anfangs ein bisschen wenig halt
bieten als rädchen gibt sind sie jetzt
der fall die ganze tier schuhe hin alter
kann man einfach sehr leicht umknicken
und dann bin ich ein zwei drei mal
umgeknickt oder so die w2 sehr leicht
aus wenn man die an hat aber die sind
tatsächlich von tragekomfort jetzt ein
bisschen instabil sag ich mal diese
schuhe hier habe ich mir in london
gekauft als ich mit dominik porschen bei
der premiere von the machine war
brauchte ich halt noch irgendwelche
schulrätin monika mit der premiere ist
natürlich machen wir ein bisschen
schicker anziehen da wir diese schuhe
gekauft hat l ganz so eltern so ein
weilchen ganz laden oder kam
die hatten nur solche schuhe diesen
engel kanals also ich finde ganzen
farbkombination ganz cooling mit diesem
rot-weißen hier drin und mit der
kombination von blauen von außen die
trage ich sehr gerne bei irgendwelchen
sachen
ja kommen wir jetzt auch schon zu den
letzten fünf partien die ich hier schon
stehen haben und zwar so dass wir die
schuhe die ich am häufigsten an habe
diese fünf pause zwischen den ich immer
so ein bisschen wechsel zu denen gehören
nämlich auch diese laser schwarze die
ich mir allerdings leider viel zu
größten größe gekauft habe weil ich die
den tag danach gekauft habe wo ich beim
arzt war und der meinte dass sich
einlagen tragen muss und dann bist du
jetzt mal anders als größte größer
kaufen ich koche die 46 habe sonst 44
anhalt sind riesig die schuhe bin ich
aber cool also kann man auch cool hose
hoch krempeln oder die schuhe anziehen
find ich sehr nice die nike blazer
obwohl die auch schon wenn sie draußen
locker schon so seit 67 jahren oder so
neben den weißen bands die ich euch
gerade schon gezeigt habe habe ich auch
noch diese welt die habe ich mir in
berlin gekauft als ich mit sk in berlin
war das war vor der auch vor ihren zu
einer film-premiere das war bei star
wars wo der neue film rauskam buch in
berlin bei der premiere waren ja das
sind ganz schlicht weiße band muss ich
glaube ich nicht viel zu sagen kann man
ganz cool zu einem weißen oder schwarzen
hose timo die youtuber alter das in
anderen bands mein gott sind weiß im
bett kommen wir zu dem vierten und
letzten paar wenn's was ich benutze das
dann solche
laurenz mit so braun schnürsenkeln und
von ihnen auch frauen und hier so ein
bisschen lena elemente die sache mit
diesen schuhen ist man denkt erst mal
jungs sind ganz normale bands ich wollte
mir die unbedingt in deutschland
irgendwo kaufen und die sind überall
ausverkauft die kriegt man in
deutschland nicht mal meiner größe
höchstens bei amazon irgendwo und dann
musste ich die in amerika bestellen und
die sind miliz soll dann in deutschland
gerade angekommen bevor ich für drei
wochen im urlaub war und dann nach zwei
wochen werden hier wieder zurückgesandt
da musste wurden die zurückgesendet nach
amerika dann kam ich wieder hier an hat
den zeitgewinn direkt zum zeuge oder
gefahren dieser täter wurden meine
schuhe ja die sind seit einer woche
wieder in amerika musst du neu bezahlen
die schuhe an sich habe ich glaube ich
50 dollar gekostet die ganzen hin und
herschicken scheiße allerdings 75 dollar
aber die sind einfach ultra bequem auch
für sommer perfekt geeignet also dessen
meine lieblingsband die hier hatte und
derzeit glaube ich auch somit meine
lieblingsschuhe kommen wir nun zu den
letzten beiden sneakern die ich habe und
zwar sind das einmal nike international
ist in blau orange die hab ich mir
bestellt als ich mit max egger kran
kraft am urlaub war vor dass man die
lügen vier jahren oder so das halt so
krass weil ich hatte damals schon die
schuhgröße 44 anhalt und die habe ich
jetzt immer noch das heißt seit vier
jahren seitdem ich 16 bin sind meine
füße nicht mehr gewachsen
schon lange zeit sind für mich die
bequemsten mikes die es gibt also alle
sagen ja irgendwie hier ist doch noch
hier die und das und er max ich finde
die international
die bequemsten einst als straßenschuhe
die es irgendwie gibt also ich weiß
nicht ist meine subjektive einschätzung
von der ganzen sache und ja das sind
meine international ist kommen wir nun
zu den letzten pass in die gasse
wahrscheinlich auch schon im titel
gelesen hat und zwar meine jesus ich
habe mir echt gesagt als ich mir die
bestehe aber die haben stadt geschlagen
also das sind die oxford annecys in
größe 45 eine halb oder oder 46 es gar
nicht genau die sind wir auf jeden fall
auch ein bisschen zu groß weil bei denen
schon ist es ja so wie kannst du nicht
einfach mal anprobieren dass die allein
die schuhe zu kriegen ist schon eine
kunst für sich ich weiß nicht ich habe
hier bestellt weil ich die farbe einfach
geil finde ich liebe beige und ich liebe
diese opfer tennisschuhe farbe whatever
und kann das perfekt kombinieren mit ein
paar anderen t shirts und politik
besitzer viele kaufen sich diese schuhe
als wertanlage weil man die glaube ich
für damals 200 oder 300 euro kaufen
konnte mittlerweile ist der wert bei
1500 oder so viele fragen sich
wahrscheinlich auch junge luca die
videos sind deutlich fällt ich meine ich
ich hab selber nicht so viel ahnung von
sneaker ich habe irgendwo zu sagen halt
fast gar keine ahnung dass das bringt
ganz gut auf den punkt nur justin ecke
pixel wolf und die superstar komische
mensch da und alle anderen und freunde
von mir sagen das sind echte von daher
also das sind das ist die punkte unten
drunter und einige erkennen dass er auch
an den abständen hier von dieser lasse
oder an
es gibt aber auch an diesem logo ihr
vorne oder canaria nimani das logo das
ist also oder oder von innen also es
sind echte sind muss ich sagen wie ich
die bequemsten schuhe die ich habe ich
habe zwar schon mal den international
ist gesagt das ist dass sie für mich
auch ultra bequem sind sind die
bequemsten nike für mich da sind die
bequemsten adidas ich habe aber noch ein
paar adidas sind diese schuhe
ich finde ich genau mein schuh gefallen
man läuft mit diesen schuhen so als
würde man sich auch noch wolken bewegen
das liegt einfach daran weil die in die
sonne keine ahnung 14 meter sohle haben
oder so und das ist halt einfach gras
mais und die zu tragen ich versteh halt
diese ganze diskussion diese schuhe
nicht natürlich sind die limitiert und
von carneoo und über adidas und so es
gibt davon die so viele und so und
deswegen sind wir auch so teuer aber ich
weiß nicht wieso sich daran so wieder
aufgabe ich habe eigentlich gesagt wenn
ich sie mir kaufe kaufe ich für mich
selbst nicht um mich irgendwie als was
besseres darzustellen von wegen hey
schaut mich an die jobs weg ich habe
dieses dann habe ich dir voll
ausgetragen und hat dann mal irgendwie
nach zwei monaten oder so ein foto davon
eines eps schätzung packen wie ich die
sun hatte beim autofahren und ich habe
halt unterbewusst so gar nicht auf
geachtet werden so zeigen sie aber guck
mal geil das wetter ist jetzt im auto
bleiben also a luca hat dieses und alle
schreiben so rum oder sogar die echten
und stimmt das und hier justin stimmt
das seerecht anderen luca echt und
freunde sind schuhe schild macht euch
verrückte faktor so ich schreib morgen
die person ich dass das wird nicht gut
enden für mich sind jedes ganze weile
schuhe
ich bin froh dass ich die habe und ich
mag die farbe und es hat sich geräumt
naja jeder der irgendwie sachen die er
feiert weise nicht die einfache annika
die anderen sportwagen die anderen keine
wohnungen bei mir ist ich feiere pizza
ja solche pizzen vorstellen oder so
damit will ich sagen was ist jetzt auch
schon vom heutigen video viele hatten
halt gefragt sie ihren gewinn dort hieß
es zeigt uns die noch mal oder allgemein
deine schuhe und ja ihr habt ihr jetzt
eine meinung die ich zeig euch mal ganz
kurz wie das bei mir auf dem boden
aussieht uns war das sind meine
kompletten shows viele das war es jetzt
hier vom video ich hoffe es hat euch
gefallen
ich habe mal eine andere kamera getestet
die ich mir bestellt habe ich werde aber
wahrscheinlich wieder zurück sein außer
gesagt jetzt jolokia die qualität ist
echt viel besser als bei dem letzten
video was ihr euch hier mal irgendwo
verlinke da habe ich die andere kamera
benutzt hatten am besten meine
kommentare welche qualität wir besser
findet weil ich mich da ja man
verbessern möchte bleiben hat man sonst
wenn es euch gefallen hat freut mich
immer eine bewertung und wir